[Music]
hi uh welcome to a big
beach on the west coast of Vancouver
Island and uh let's talk about learning
the 4 beat cork
screw um cuz that's fun for things like
you get a lot of Hang Time with it um
which can be great for
performance also it lets you do moves
like the Matrix so um pretty fun Move To
Learn as a
prerequisite you want to be able to do a
very smooth cork screw so you can slow
down and control it if your cork screw
doesn't look like this one hand at a
time learn to do it really slow and
controlled around your arm you can go
over with a lot of control and under and
see how my hand is going with the
movement that's really useful you can
also go over your
head but ideally you want to be able to
choose to go just over your arm or over
your head once you can do that one hand
at a time one hand if we're going
clockwise the left hand leads and the
right hand follows it if you're going
counterclockwise the right hand leads
and the left hand follows it so that's
your
prerequisite so if you can do that uh
goes like
this I'm going to face we can kind of
face this way together so we're going
clockwise now we want to look at the
bottom to the top my left is leading
leads down leads up leads down leads up
and the left passes our belly the belly
and over the belly and over you're going
to do a second Circle past your belly
and as you do that you're going to let
your wrists wind up so to see how that
works just let your left po
dangle
get your right po going gently clockwise
and see how I'm making this Nook with my
wrist I'm going to let my right hand has
to go around that Nook to get above my
left arm so watch How I do that I snake
around it to get
above and helpful to kind of pretty
relaxed with that so takes a
practice now once I'm up there the left
po can
join so that's the thing the right poy
is going to lead to the top and then the
left po can start
moving so once you practice that you
could also try it with the left po
circling clockwise same thing the right
PO is going to snake around it to get to
the top now you'll have some muscle
memory and you'll probably do this at
first you'll
goek and your left hand will go to the
top first because you're used to doing
that so that's what you have to overcome
in that that's why it might be helpful
just to let it hang to get used to
letting the right po lead to the top and
once it's up there they can both start
moving So eventually with the left
moving you let the right lead to the top
and then you go back to your cork screw
and you look at how the left is leading
past the belly over belly over belly
twice and as it does the second Circle
past your belly the right takes over
snakes around and leads to the top
that's the bottom half of the fourbe
Quirk
screw the top half you just kind of do
the opposite but you can't let the PO
hang um because it's in the way if it's
hanging so for the top half you could
try spinning it so again it's
going
clockwise and what your right PO is
going to do is your right PO is going to
try to go around your wrist and you want
to imagine you want to get it below
while the left PO is still up there
which which is not easy to do so you can
just kind of screw around with that a
little bit and maybe hit yourself a lot
but uh ideally you want that's what you
want to imagine you're going to do is
the right
po it's going to do that when it does it
the left po can follow
it and again you'll have some muscle
memory that's going to want the left po
the lead you'll go here we go and you'll
just do that because that's what you've
done I don't know hundreds of times or
thousands of times
um so if you do let's try again from
maybe leading so look at my left foot
goes past my nose past my nose you have
to go past your nose
twice and it's during the second time
past your nose that the right one will
snake around it so past your nose past
your nose that's once then it's going to
be once
twice and then the right leads
down pass the nose once twice right lead
down right leads up right snake strand
go down snake strand going up snake
strand going down snake Str going up so
we've switched from the at first it was
the left leading leads up leads down
leads up leads down second Circle the
right takes over and then it's the right
leading down right leading up right
leading down right leading up and I
recommend learning to do this nice and
slow and controlled so the PO are almost
hanging from your
hands and then that's really fun now you
can go over your head
later or you could go just around your
arms and it's a nice thing to do like if
you say you're performing with fire it's
uh you can do that at the beginning of a
burn because it's very slow and
controlled and kind of
dramatic um but as I'll show you in
another video this is
also the way
you go
into the
[Music]
Matrix